初めて来たところです。
画材を背負って、こっちも荷物を背負って、
今日のお宿はありますか?ということで、お湯は出ますか?
そういうの難しいですよね。
1週間ずつ、初めパリに行って、それからクエルモンペランとか、山の方に入って、
南北まで何かに行って、
ニースとかね、普通のいいところでしたね。
エイスとか、
アルピスの方行って、シャモンに行って、
1週間くらい行って、
大体、移動して1週間くらい、
何時間かは必ず行って、
6、9日。
絵を描きながら。
絵を描きながら、すごい。
すごい楽しかった。
コースタン、しっかりやっていただいて、
もうちょっと、
回しましょうか。
1週間くらい、
本当だ?それ何? タイキヤ知ってそうな…クワガタ虫… クワガタだ。クワガタ取る? メスです。 フルーツの匂い。
フランスに転々として、そこで泊まって、何日間からそこで生活するから、市場に行ってみたり、その地域のなんか…山の方はお肉のウサギとかね、そういうもので市場に行くと、こうやってウサギの耳もって品定めしてるんでしょ?
ウサギ食べるんですよね。 ペットじゃなくって、あれは食べるんだっていう。
ちょっとワイルドな感じでしたね。ウサギの耳もこう…買うか買うのか…
食べ物もちょっと…フランスの味に疲れちゃって…食べ物ないかなって…
ベーコンっていうのがあって、あっ、ベーコンなら食べれると。日本の感覚って薄く切ったベーコンを…って感じだったら、なんか酢漬けのキャベツのこれぐらいのベーコンがどんどん来て…
フランスの…フランスの…フランスの…何もかも…なんか、こっちのイメージ…